Mika is 4 years old an aid worker had
sex with his mother when she was just 15
that's rape in many countries because
grandfather admits I never met his
father but he laughed but everyone can
see he's white you just have to look at
the boy his mother franciene says she
was wearing her school uniform when she
was stopped in Goma by an aid worker who
was driving a vehicle branded with the
charity's name I was coming back from
school and he gave me his phone number
he told me to change out of my school
uniform and come back and see him I was
just 15
[Music]
franciene and tens of thousands like
earth live in desperately poor
conditions in the DRC jobs are scarce
and most just scrapin existence from day
to day the young woman was promised food
aid and payment for her school fees plus
a new life abroad in return for sex but
it all ended abruptly when she became
pregnant with Micah
two months later the day I told him I
was pregnant he was very surprised he
told me not to tell anyone and he'd sort
everything I never saw him again when
laverna Francine has named him on
Micah's birth certificate she says she
saw his charity identity card when we
contacted the charity they insisted they
had no record of him and couldn't risk
wasting time tracking him down if his
name was misspelled and Francine is far
from the only one Saffy says she had a
long relationship with an aid worker
working she claims with the UN for which
she received food and money she's got a
picture she says is of him but again
when she became pregnant he abruptly cut
contact suffering a lot we're both
suffering a lot were just existing by
the grace of God she says both women say
they alerted the charities and aid
officers concerned but their claims were
ignored brushed off as attempt to
exploit the charities the investigation
by MPs finds otherwise
the DRC has the largest UN peacekeeping
force in the world hits blue helmets are
considered vital in protecting millions
of Congolese who need aid of the decades
of unrest and fighting
there are numerous aid agencies doing
vital work but the MPS investigation and
our own found it's exactly these
conditions which make it fertile ground
for abuse by sexual predators the MPS
say the aid sector as a whole has been
aware of this sexual exploitation by its
own personnel for years and has
collectively failed to address it the
MPS call it complacency verging on
complicity Francine and little Micah are
the victims of this but no one is taking
her or her little boy seriously Alex
Crawford Sky News reporting from the
Democratic Republic of Congo